Vì bán nhân dân thành phố Hàn đôi và bán thành kế hoạch đấu giá quyền xử dụng đất năm 2020.
Với quy mô lớn, nhằm khai thác hiệu quả của lực đất đài và tăng tù gần sách,
theo kế hoạch trong năm 2020, trong khách xấu toàn thành phố sự kiến tổ chức đấu giá ba chăm lình xấu dự án,
khú đất với tổng dân tích khoảng 20% phải chí mới hát ca.
Khương bào gồm dân tích xây dựng hạch tăng ký thuật.
Tổng số tiền chúng đấu giá ước đặt khoảng 16% của thành phố Bệnh tỷ đồng.
Thành phố cho biết việc đấu giá quyền xử dụng đất, nhằm khai thác hiệu quả của đất
đáp ứng như cầu xử dụng đất của người dân và dân nghiệp,
đồng thời tạo của nguồn tù cho ngần sách cac up.
Mô lực này sẽ được xử dụng đề đầu tư xây dựng hạch tăng ký thuật,
hạ tăng xa hội và trên khai chương trình xây dựng đồng tôn mới,
theo chỉ đạo của thành quy hồ đồng dân dân và uống bán nhân dân thành phố Hàn đôi.
Mình kện đó việc đấu ra đất còn góc phần dài quyết điều cầu nhá ở
đừng khá chơi lượng bệ sống người dân, đồng thời hồn thiện hệ thống hạch tăng
tăng tắc các khu đủ thi mới và khu dân kư nông thôn theo hướng văn mình
khiến đại, phù hợp với quy hệ chung xây dựng tủ đồ.
Theo kế hoại các đơn vị được giá tụ chức đấu giá có chức nghiệm thủ đủ.
Và kìa thời, số tiền chúng đấu giá nước vào khoảng nhà nước,
đồng thời từ khiến hồn chá phần vốn đa ứng và nột đình xách theo quy định
bảo đam khoảng lý trực trẻ mình bệnh vốn thủ tiền đại.